Now, we should be able to find the most
appropriate URL that our app should use.
Based on the UX wireframes
we saw earlier, we want
the weather forecast for a week's worth
of data given a certain postal cost.
For the purposes of this quiz and our
example code that we'll be showing you.
We'll be using the Mountain View
postal code, which is 94043.
By all means you should use the postal
code for your own location.
Or you can use city name or
latitude, longitude coordinates.
If it doesn't find your
location based on postal code.
Try using postal code followed by
a comma, followed by the country code.
See the discussion forum for
more examples.
Next, we want the response from
the server to be in JSON format.
And we also want the temperatures
to be reported in metric units.
We choose metric for
doing the query, but our UI will be
able to displace celsius or
fahrenheit based ion user preferences.
Wnd we'll just do
the conversion ourselves.
Enter the URL in the box that
fulfills these requirements.